[Música]
se trata de una condena histórica la
Corte Interamericana de los Derechos
Humanos condenó al Estado colombiano por
las violaciones a los Derechos Humanos
por más de dos décadas contra unos 6000
integrantes o simpatizantes del partido
político Unión patriótica un partido de
izquierdas que surgió de un proceso de
paz fallido con la entonces guerrillas
de las FARC y que militó en la política
colombiana entre los años 1980 y 1990 la
corte determinó la responsabilidad en la
persecución Y prácticamente Exterminio
de miles de personas que pertenecían a
la upe como era conocida en esa época
los ponemos en contexto con el siguiente
reportaje que preparó la redacción de
France 24
[Aplausos]
se trató de un Exterminio político ante
los ojos de un país entero la historia
del partido de la unión patriótica up de
lata parte de la crueldad de la
violencia vivida en Colombia a finales
del siglo XX el partido nació en 1985
producto de unas negociaciones entre la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC y el
gobierno del expresidente colombiano
Belisario Betancourt su bandera Amarilla
simbolizaba un deseo convertir al
partido en una alternativa en un
escenario político dominado por décadas
por dos partidos tradicionales el
liberal y el conservador su conformación
se convirtió en una tercera vía y fue
vista como una posibilidad de
representación política para una parte
del electorado a la vez buscaba ser un
mecanismo de transición de las armas a
la política de las Farc
en 1986 consiguieron 15 escaños en el
congreso
pero su proyecto quedó inconcluso por el
asesinato de sus representantes año tras
año la violencia fue perpetrada por
grupos paramilitares en Alianza con
sectores de la política tradicional la
fuerza pública y grupos empresariales
así lo anunciaba su líder en los años 90
desde luego que nosotros sabemos muy
bien cómo son las conexiones de estos
grupos con con autoridades y con la
propios sectores de la inteligencia
militar una violencia con enormes
dimensiones que incluso cobró la vida de
dos candidatos presidenciales en 2002 el
Consejo Nacional electoral le retiró la
personería jurídica al no conseguir
escaños suficientes una decisión
cuestionada solo entre 1984 y 2002 según
cifras del observatorio de memoria y
conflicto más de 3000 de sus miembros
fueron asesinados
hasta este lunes sólo 219 víctimas eran
reconocidas oficialmente por el estado
colombiano y su responsabilidad era solo
vista de manera indirecta ahora
condenado el estado deberá saldar parte
de su deuda histórica con sus familiares
y sobrevivientes
pues es muy claro el tribunal
internacional entonces Consideró que
hubo un plan de Exterminio sistemático
hubo participación de agentes estatales
también hubo tolerancia y consentimiento
factores que constituyen un crimen de
lesa humanidad desde el gobierno de
Colombia a través de Iván Velázquez
ministro de defensa respondieron que van
a respetar esta sentencia y las
recomendaciones escuchemos
vamos a examinar
las órdenes y recomendaciones de la
Corte Interamericana en este fallo en el
que ha declarado la responsabilidad del
Estado colombiano por la muerte de
los integrantes de tantos de tantos
miles de La Unión patriótica
en todo lo que corresponda al
reconocimiento de responsabilidades del
Estado
así las cosas la corte entonces obliga
al estado de la República de Colombia a
iniciar impulsar reabrir y continuar en
un plazo de no mayor a dos años y
también concluir en un plazo razonable
con la mayor diligencia investigación y
con el fin de establecer la verdad de
los hechos relativos a graves
violaciones a los derechos humanos y
también determinar las responsabilidades
penales también pidió efectuar la
búsqueda de los militantes que siguen
desaparecidos también realizar un acto
Público de reconocimiento de
responsabilidad a nivel internacional y
Establecer un día de conmemoración a las
víctimas del genocidio y también
construir un monumento En su memoria Qué
significa entonces para el Estado
colombiano que llegue esta condena Qué
significa para el proceso de
construcción de paz de Colombia es esto
el cierre digamos lo de un capítulo
oscuro la violencia de estado en
Colombia si bien en el pasado se
persiguió se señaló y se asesinó a los
integrantes de la up esta realidades
está hablando de la persecución los
señalamientos y los asesinatos siguen
siendo actuales en Colombia hay otros
sectores de la sociedad que se ven
Víctimas de este mismo tipo de procesos
el blanco y el objetivo pues ha cambiado
a lo largo de los años pero ya lo vamos
a analizar Quiénes son los que están
siendo afectados ahora no son los
integrantes de los partidos de la
izquierda son líderes sociales líderes
medioambientales diferentes sectores de
la sociedad colombiana entre otros ahora
no siempre se puede señalar al Estado
colombiano los actores también han
cambiado porque precisamente la el
conflicto colombiano y la coyuntura
política del país también ha cambiado
todo eso lo vamos a analizar en unos
minutos aquí en el debate de France 24
por eso hoy en nuestro programa Colombia
la up partido asesinado es nuestro tema
de discusión y análisis y para analizar
este tema hemos invitado a Adriana
otálora ella es profesora de la
Universidad de La Salle también es
coordinadora de la línea de ciudadanía
ética y política del doctorado en
estudios de desarrollo y territorio
también está con nosotros en el estudio
de France 24 Néstor rozanilla Él es
director ejecutivo del centro de
estudios en seguridad y paz en Colombia
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de este programa hacen parte
del debate pueden dejar los comentarios
y las preguntas que deseen a través de
las redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook también en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba
franz24_s@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f-24 todo
junto no olviden también que todos los
contenidos están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Adriana Bienvenida al programa Gracias
por acompañarnos hoy en el estudio de
France 24 Adriana y la pregunta de Punto
de partida para este debate
Qué sensación le deja usted esta condena
que llega de la Corte Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos contra el estado
colombiano Santiago gracias por la
invitación y bueno la las sensaciones de
Esperanza
este condena significa la reparación
Para las víctimas Pero también es la
esperanza para la democracia del pueblo
colombiano para el ejercicio real de la
ciudadanía y por este lado Néstor
Bienvenido al programa Gracias por
acompañarnos la misma pregunta Qué
sensación le deja usted que análisis se
hace de esta condena al Estado
colombiano tres cosas rápidas lo primero
es que en Colombia Ya podemos hablar de
genocidio quiere decir que fue una
práctica y usa la palabra importante
sistemática por parte del Estado por
pertenecer a un grupo político entonces
Hoy podemos decir que es algo que hay un
genocidio en Colombia cosa que era un
debate antes y hoy ya es una realidad lo
segundo yo creo que es un Punto de
partida en un final en qué sentido que
nos falta puntualmente son los nombres
las instituciones y los rangos de
Quiénes fueron los responsables de este
genocidio la corte todavía lo deja muy
digamos muy Macro que hay una
responsabilidad del Estado colombiano
pero necesitamos son los nombres aquí
comienza un segundo capítulo que es por
parte de la justicia Colombia que hacer
más difícil porque hacerlo a nivel
internacional es fácil pero que dentro
de la institucionalidad comience a
saberse esa verdad va a ser lo más
difícil y lo tercero que también es un
papel es un espacio importante para la
jep Porque allá están llegando muchos de
los responsables a contar sus verdades
entonces necesitamos abrir más espacios
sostener la jep no dejarla cerrar para
que esa verdad del genocidio de la upe
la podamos conocer cada vez más a fondo
usted habla que ya la instancia o este
siguiente capítulo que se abre es la
investigación por parte del Estado
colombiano Que tanto se puede creer en
la institucionalidad en las
instituciones que tienen que dar
paso a estas investigaciones como lo
está solicitando la corte a hoy 30 años
de impunidad y ha sido sistemática la
impunidad así como mataron a la gente
sistemáticamente la impunidad la
desviación de las investigaciones Y es
que dentro de esto pues tuvimos
magnicidios no grandes dirigentes
políticos fueron asesinados que también
quedaron en la impunidad Entonces
primero hay una impunidad de la
institucionalidad y lo y es
fundamentalmente porque los los
determinadores hoy muchos siguen en el
poder y hoy muchos Siguen con nexos con
la clase política con las fuerzas
militares tienen mucho poder por eso es
que no se avanzan estas investigaciones
entonces la corte da un paso importante
es un espaldarazo y yo creo que los que
hasta hoy valientemente han podido
hacernos conocer algo de la verdad del
conflicto colombiano ha sido la jep
entonces Esperamos que en ese espacio de
Justicia transicional se pueda conocer
cada vez más sobre todo Quiénes estaban
detrás determinando un genocidio como
este Adriana continuó con usted por este
lado de la mesa lo que significa esto
dentro del contexto de la historia del
conflicto colombiano qué capítulo se
cierra acá esto Qué significa para la
historia de ese conflicto que vemos que
no Solamente era un capítulo de guerra
entre el estado y los grupos
guerrilleros sino que aquí esto
incursionó a una violencia de estado
hacia un partido político puntual se
cierra un proceso que es un proceso
parcialmente culminado porque como
decías al principio no se ha terminado
la violencia contra los líderes sociales
en ni los líderes ambientalistas ni
quien se atreve a pensar distinto o
hablar fuertemente
se cierra Pues por supuesto el dolor el
dolor que causa el haber perdido un ser
querido alguien con convicciones
dispuesto a transformar el país porque
esta edad es el partido político Sí este
partido político tuvo la posibilidad de
transformar la sociedad colombiana y se
la negaron dejándonos sin voz a la gran
mayoría de los ciudadanos y ciudadanas
es también una manera de volver a hablar
de que nuestros jóvenes sepan que sí se
puede protestar que si se puede
protestar
me preguntó para poner en contexto a las
personas que están fuera de las
fronteras colombianas que no están
empapados del conflicto colombiano que
es un conflicto que se ha extendido a lo
largo de muchas décadas Cuál era el
contexto de Colombia en esa época que
llevó a ese proceso fallido como lo
mencionábamos en la introducción con la
guerrilla de las FARC que dio origen a
este partido y por qué empezó esta
persecución puntualmente armemos el
rompecabezas entre los dos empiezo
Entonces por este lado para el contexto
es que se intentó hacer un proceso de
paz colectivo la famosa coordinadora
guerrillera de Simón Bolívar se
intentaron que los diferentes grupos
guerrilleros sigamos llegaran una agenda
conjunta pero que tuvimos lección
aprendida a hoy cada guerrilla tiene un
interés político una metodología y una
teoría de guerra diferente no tiene nada
que ver las Far con el eln la gente
digamos a priori pensaría pero son
guerrillas y están en el monte en
fusiladas pero mientras una tenía una
política y una teoría política marxista
leninista la otra tenía una teoría
foquista eso materializado en la guerra
también eran diferencias muy entonces
tuvimos diferentes guerrillas que nunca
se entendieron pero las FARC intentó dar
un paso y dijo si intentemos saber si un
proyecto político Ya puede empezarse a
gestar en Colombia y que sea como el
punto clave para un un nuevo intento de
negociación y ahí van a hacer la up qué
fue lo que molestó A esa clase política
tradicional en el contexto de la Guerra
Fría además fue que empezaron a tener
mucha fuerza y fue que recaudaron todo
un cantidad de intereses y de
movimientos de izquierda Colombia se
divide en dos partidos o liberal o
conservador entre comillas derecha
izquierda pero los liberales ya no no
representaban realmente a esos a esos
digamos esos inicios políticos y la up
apareció como movimiento realmente de
izquierda que pudo llevar y recoger
muchos movimientos y eso les dio músculo
sobre todo les dio músculo electoral y
empezaron a poner gente en los cargos
públicos y ahí fue donde vive una
reacción muy fuerte de la derecha los
partidos tradicionales de las fuerzas
militares etcétera en contra de la Up
eso en el contexto político en el
contexto social entonces Adriana como
estaba Colombia en esa época como en esa
época veníamos del estatuto de seguridad
del presidente turbay fruto de la
violencia que se había heredado desde
Jorge eliécer Gaitán en 1949 es decir
tenemos medio siglo precisamente de allí
surgen las guerrillas en las que se ha
minimizado y ha callado esa protesta
social Pero también el debate político
el dejarnos únicamente circunscritos Ah
partido liberal y conservador nos limita
la posibilidad de elegir ahora Como le
estaba diciendo Néstor este grupo La up
logra consolidarse en el proceso de paz
No únicamente por integrantes del
amnistiados del grupo de las FARC sino
también por miembros del partido
comunista con unas ideas bastante más
robustas más fuertes de la izquierda y
con representación en las regiones más
alejadas del país las más pobres también
del país que no tenían una voz
significativa en el gobierno y eso hace
que se cambie el modelo Así que se
comience a pensar en la voz de los
pobres en la voz de los que no tienen
oportunidad de acumular capital que la
voz de los campesinos y se significa una
amenaza para el establecimiento
colombiano del momento así como
significó Jorge eliécer Gaitán en 1949
es un miedo al cambio es un miedo a la a
la base al pueblo
es significativo que esta condena llegue
justamente a Adriana cuando en Colombia
está en el gobierno el primer partido el
primer gobierno de izquierda que tiene
una tendencia de izquierda es
significativo para la historia para la
política colombiana esta esta condena Y
además que sea un gobierno de izquierda
que asuma como lo vimos en la
introducción del programa que sí que
aceptan la la condena aceptan también
las recomendaciones y que le van a dar
marcha a todas las recomendaciones que
ellos han pedido y que lo que falta por
hacer como nos decía Néstor en este
siguiente capítulo que apenas va a
empezar eso es significativo
significativo e incluso constituye una
paradoja para el presidente Petro porque
está representando al Estado colombiano
tiene la responsabilidad de defender las
instituciones públicas colombianas las
mismas que nos fallaron durante 30 años
en poder darle una solución interna a
los crímenes que se estaban cometiendo Y
por supuesto frenar el ritmo de estos
crímenes pero al mismo tiempo viene de
una corriente ideológica y de una base
política y social que incluida la up es
la que lo pone en el poder en este
momento el hecho de que la up haya
logrado mantenerse durante todos estos
años como movimiento partido político de
ideología hace que le dé más fuerza al
movimiento que en este momento acompaña
al presidente Petro esa convocatoria de
llamar al país pero por otra parte
implica una mayor responsabilidad aún
como representante político frente a la
democracia colombiana para cumplir de
manera satisfactoria a pesar de las
dificultades institucionales que
significa esto la sentencia de la la
reparación dificultades institucionales
Pero entonces son garantías esto nos
garantiza que ese segundo capítulo que
usted mencionaba Néstor va a ponerse en
marcha porque ya sabemos no solamente en
Colombia sino en en América Latina como
les cuesta a los gobiernos poner en
marcha todo tipo de programas o este
tipo de sentencias siempre esto empieza
traspapelarse y se va perdiendo y va
pasando el tiempo esto es garantía que
está el presidente Petro en este momento
en el poder que esto va a evolucionar va
a empezar ese segundo capítulo a moverse
yo creo que tenemos la esperanza pero no
la certeza no la certeza sería que
tuviéramos también una una rama judicial
comprometida realmente con sacar esas
investigaciones adelante hay miembros
digamos que han intentado hacerlo pero
cada vez que es de la rama judicial pasa
eso venían las amenazas venían la
persecución Entonces esto un reto
digamos no solo para el gobierno sino
para toda la institucionalidad
colombiana eso es lo primero y lo
segundo uniendo con algo que tú también
que estamos viviendo El problema todavía
o sea es un tema vigente entonces
asesinato de líderes sociales el país
donde más Asesinan líderes ambientales y
el país donde en el año 2020 en el
gobierno de Iván Duque se destapa un
gran escándalo de la persecución a
periodista de Defensores de derechos
humanos y líderes De oposición por parte
del ejército O sea que esto sigue siendo
una realidad la la Colombia de la up no
es que haya no haya cambiado tanto a la
Colombia del 2023 ahí está el gran reto
Cómo hacer para que eso se transforme Y
mira que yo me hacía esta reflexión Los
que participaron en la up hay muchos que
siguen con poder o están conexiones pero
cuando uno va a ver quiénes son los que
chuzaban en el 2020 Son nuevos o sea que
el tema es cultural y generacional
dentro de esas instituciones Piensan en
la Guerra Fría todavía Ven a la
izquierda como el enemigo entonces ahí
viene un problema más difícil porque
puede ser que capturemos a uno pero si
desde las escuelas de formación sigue se
repite ese discurso Pues realmente
problemas no se acaba de fondo claro no
se acaba de fondo la la condena es
puntual pidiendo que se instrumentalice
de alguna forma que se garantice la no
repetición pero es que aquí no es que lo
vayamos a repetir es que lo estamos
viviendo en el día a día justamente
ahora la flip ha empezado a hacer
algunas denuncias en torno al presidente
Petro por la cantidad de mensajes que
publica de su cuenta en Twitter en los
que señala directamente por ejemplo los
medios de comunicación ya hay alertas a
nivel internacional de cierta
persecución por parte del gobierno
colombiano algunos medios de
comunicación en ese país suramericano
entonces creo que es la condena viene
difícil para ponerla en marcha por parte
del Estado porque no es un episodio que
se terminó y que puede suceder sino que
está sucediendo en este momento no Esto
va más allá que simplemente perseguir a
un partido a un partido político en
Colombia la persecución es sistemática a
diferentes niveles cómo lo ve Adriana sí
no solamente sistemática y no solamente
la la persecución sino la forma en que
la sociedad concibe al otro esa
dificultad que tenemos para poder
incluir otras voces otras personas y las
necesidades de estar buscando enemigos
en los distintas voces que van
emergiendo en la democracia colombiana
si pensamos en términos de los procesos
de paz tenemos un reto grandísimo
ahorita con el proceso de paz con las
Farc la negociación de La Habana porque
parte de lo que sucedió con la up es
acallar la voz en parte porque no se
solucionaron las condiciones
estructurales del conflicto y las
condiciones que iban a desestimular que
los miembros de las FARC volvieran a la
guerra eso no se ha solucionado pero
aparte la sociedad no ha permitido que
establecer unos diálogos para que se
pueda dar una verdadera cultura de paz y
de cohesión social el reto es gigante si
nosotros no tomamos esta oportunidad
como país para poder permitir darle a
los procesos de paz los que sean con los
actores que sean posibilidad de tener
una voz política y una participación
estructurada como partido político
difícilmente vamos a lograr superar
estas condiciones actuales que sí van a
seguir permanentemente
me parece interesante y es que en
Colombia tenemos que o sea no solo fue
que la institucionalidad hizo un
genocidio Es que la institucionalidad se
alió con otros delincuentes para cometer
un genocidio O sea la alianza entre el
estado colombiano y los paramilitares
fue evidente en el genocidio de la upep
ahora el problema es que el
paramilitarismo no se acabó sino se
transformó Entonces ahora tenemos unos
cantidad de grupos Neo paramilitares que
siguen activos y que todavía tienen
poder en las regiones Entonces es como
que si todos los actores se les hubiera
cambiado el nombre pero en términos
generales siguen vivos entonces ahí está
la dificultad también pues cuando uno a
veces hace reflexiones no sé de otros
conflictos a nivel internacional uno
puede decir bueno puedo sacar lecciones
aprendidas porque el escenario cambió
por ejemplo las dictaduras del cono Sur
en Argentina y en el sur del continente
ahí hay lecciones aprendidas porque ya
se transformó el escenario pero en
Colombia no el escenario sigue
completamente vivo y con un dato para
para que los televidentes fuera del país
lo vean en el gobierno de Iván Duque
durante sus últimos tres años tuvimos
más reportada por Naciones Unidas ongs
dan datos más altos más de 60 masacres
por año o sea un país donde hay más de
60 masacres es un país en una guerra
civil y aquí nos decían que estábamos
bien en materia de seguridad entonces
sigue habiendo problema Cómo cambiar
Entonces el panorama o este tipo de
acciones este tipo de condenas de
organismos internacionales empiezan a
sembrar esa semilla para para para
cambiar ese panorama porque
los que estamos acá en Colombia lo vemos
en el día a día
Tal parece que no hay una evolución el
conflicto está en cierta forma estancado
y hay una mesa de negociación con el eln
hay un proceso de de
comunicación con la con la que era la
guerrilla de las FARC ya se convirtió en
un partido político pero los frutos de
esa Paz todavía no se ven Entonces cómo
generar un cambio en esa esa verdadera
transformación pues lo primero hay que
decir que con el conflicto armado se
transformó en qué sentido primero
tuvimos un conflicto bipartidista los
liberales contra los conservadores
después del 64 que nacen las Far el elen
y viene un Boom de los grupos
guerrilleros de la revolución cubana
etcétera ya hay una mutación del
conflicto Entonces ya no es bipartidista
por temas de tierra sino es un conflicto
en el contexto de la guerra fría con
unas guerrillas en la toma de la lucha
de la toma del Poder y después viene una
reacción contra insurgente a los
paramilitares y ahí estuvimos
enfrascados más de 30 años pero empezó
se empezó a transformar en qué sentido
los paramilitares como estructura
desaparece se transforma bandas
delincuenciales Las Far ya desaparece
como organización Armada Era la más
grande del país ahora es partido
político solo nos queda el eln qué es lo
que hemos visto nosotros en las
investigaciones en las regiones es que
estamos en una nueva espi violencia que
se llama portafolios de economía ilegal
quiere decir estos grupos ya no buscan
la toma del cuerpo de la vía las armas
no tiene un discurso político marxista
ni idealista ni nada sino que están
concentrados en las rentas ilegales que
ya ni siquiera se limitan solo al
narcotráfico manejan la minería ilegal
el tráfico ilegal de combustibles de
madera la extorsión Pero eso se
convierte en una multinacional del
crimen donde tienen muchas entradas
económicas y donde su forma y su modo de
vivir en sí mismo es es tener ese poder
criminal Entonces ya lo que y yo acaba
de llegar del Sur del Norte del cauca
perdón y lo que encontré fue eso son
chicos que no tienen discurso político
no tienen una base política pero si
tiene una cultura militar Y a partir de
eso tienen control en los territorios
bueno prácticamente el panorama no
cambia Adriana Sí si me permites Añadir
en términos de cultura política algo
fundamental es que nuestros jóvenes
puedan alzar la voz que puedan protestar
esto significa fortalecer los
movimientos sociales significa darles la
confianza de que no van a seguidos ni
estigmatizados
Yo estudié en la universidad en los 90 y
recuerdo que sí protestábamos como es
casi que natural a los jóvenes más
estudiando ciencia política pero pasito
es protestábamos que no nos escucharan
mucho bajo decibel bajo decibel porque
todo el tiempo estábamos viendo este
tipo de noticias y por supuesto que da
miedo para las familias de más tenemos
entonces unas dos generaciones en donde
hemos aprendido a quedarnos callados ese
es un primer elemento el segundo es el
fortalecimiento de los partidos
políticos porque eso también la el caso
del genocidio de la up hizo que la a la
gente le de miedo pertenecer carnetizada
al partido político ser militante activo
del partido y eso ha hecho que no exista
una estructura ideológica adecuada
suficiente y diferenciable entre los
partidos políticos en Colombia Lo cual
también va a limitar esa participación
política además que los partidos sean
atomizado mucho en Colombia hay una
política muy dispersa de una misma
tendencia pero no logran uni tampoco sus
ideas eso también genera complicaciones
a la hora de hacer una propuesta de
ofrecer un plan de acción más
contundente que resulte atractivo para
para el espectro de la ciudadanía que
vea que se puede identificar en alguno
de Pues de un espectro pero no tan
atomizado como está el escenario
colombiano hay quienes han celebrado
esta condena han celebrado que el estado
colombiano haya dado una respuesta
positiva y haya aceptado las condiciones
y las sugerencias que hace la Corte
Interamericana de los Derechos Humanos
Pero hay otros sectores de la sociedad
colombiana que no ven esto con buenos
ojos a quién le puede parecer que haber
condenado al Estado colombiano por este
genocidio no es bienvenido se creó
también un discurso negacionista frente
al tema de la up se empezó a crear un
discurso donde primero donde decían que
la up no eran tantos que los homicidios
no habían sido tantos y se limitaban era
un reconocimiento judicial más no a
entender un fenómeno Macro quienes
pueden estar interesados obviamente alas
de la clase política tradicional que
estaba muy cercanas a quien a los
paramilitares a los militares de esa
época que fueron los que perpetuaron las
peores masacres también entonces es que
había una una combinación de las formas
de Lucha como decían los grupos armados
en qué sentido desde la izquierda tenían
digamos esa ese concepto de la lógica de
la combinación de las formas pero desde
la derecha también porque habían
políticos haciendo su campaña política
Pero tenían un brazo armado ilegal que
eran los paramilitares yales de las
fuerzas militares que los acompañaban
Entonces desde ese triángulo que se
formó obviamente han generado un
discurso negacionista frente a este
hecho del genocidio de la ope significa
dejando de lado la parte del conflicto y
metiéndonos solamente en la parte
política de Adriana esto significa un
paso en la madurez política de este país
que lleva 50 años matándose izquierdas
con derechas centros o sea aquí esto se
volvió un conflicto en el que hay un
montón de actores que son difíciles de
entender en algunos casos Pero esto
representa un poco de madurez política
para el país para para la sociedad
colombiana Considero que sí y por eso
hablaba de Esperanza al principio
esperanza envasada fundada en las
instituciones que si bien por dado el
conflicto y las condiciones propias de
nuestro país No funcionaron no actuaron
de manera eficiente de manera interna si
tenemos la institucionalidad
internacional que ha acogido Colombia y
que nos da un espaldarazo a la
democracia es decir es posible que no
haya sido una de las prioridades en su
momento por distintos factores de la
institucionalidad colombiana perseguir
este tipo de crímenes pero en este
momento ya se siente un precedente de la
no comisión de este tipo de actos la
defensa del derecho a la libre expresión
a la libre asociación a la posibilidad
de que la gente pueda otra vez unirse y
hablar en público yo esperaría con esto
que las elecciones y los momentos de
elecciones otra vez vuelvan a hacer una
fiesta pues es una esperanza en unos
años una fiesta como fue antes de
incluso de la constitución del 91 la
gente salía celebraba hablaba libremente
comienzan estos asesinatos Y por
supuesto nadie quiere saber qué piensa
el vecino ni que lo vayan a saber de qué
parte o partido soy yo esto nos plantea
la necesidad de sumar nuevas voces que
además ahorita para las elecciones de
congreso vimos que se sumaron nuevas
voces
a la política colombiana que si logramos
que permanezcan deliberantes pero
podremos tener un avance en la
democracia suponiendo un escenario y Es
simplemente para analizar algunas de las
posibilidades entre un poco en el
terreno de las especulación si el
gobierno colombiano del Estado
colombiano no cumple con este tipo de
condenas Néstor que puede suceder a
nivel internacional esto Qué
implicaciones tiene para el estado
antes de responder te sumo una cosa de
lo que decía Adriana y era que el
mensaje que queda esto es que hacía ya
imponía la legislación interna y en el
ambiente jurídico interno a nivel
internacional no y que los estados
tienen que entender eso que por más que
violen derechos humanos dentro de sus
países a nivel internacional sí pueden
llegar a ser condenados por instancias
internacionales eso es fundamental ahora
lo segundo digamos que caso hipotético
no pase nada pues vienen una serie de
sanciones Generalmente diplomáticas y ya
cuando es muy grave viene unas sanciones
económicas generalmente se quedan los
diplomático pero es muy simbólico al
decir que y para qué sirven esas
sanciones diplomáticas es para cuando
vengan empresas internacionales las las
organizaciones internacionales dicen a
las multinacionales no inviertan este
país porque este país es violador de los
derechos humanos y auspicia la violación
de los Derechos Humanos eso afecta la
inversión extranjera directa y tiene un
impacto económico en los países entonces
las sanciones diplomáticas la única
forma de tener dientes es en el tema de
la inversión extranjera porque Más allá
de la corte se quedaría corta es lo que
pasó por ejemplo con el documento que le
dan a Iván Duque después del estallido
Social le dijeron Todas estas son las
recomendaciones hay violaciones a los
derechos humanos y que hizo el Gobierno
Duque nada y no pasó nada pero más allá
de un tema una sanción simbólica pues
hay que jugar con el tema de plomacia y
la sanción económica esto pesa mucho
entonces para el futuro democrático
colombiano sienta precedentes para de
cara usted mencionaba elecciones en las
que se han ido sumando diferentes voces
a Adriana pero de Cara a las elecciones
o a los futuros procesos electorales en
Colombia esto En qué beneficia esto que
buenas bases de jaboque o Qué síntomas
puede generar para sus comicios
esperaría un fortalecimiento de partidos
políticos y no movimientos electorales
que en esa atomización que mencionabas
en efecto terminan en esto no partidos
con una estructura ideológica cumpliendo
los las funciones propias de los
partidos como son la socialización
política poder establecer redes con los
jóvenes que puedan debatir soluciones
para el país y que tengan representación
fundamentalmente en las regiones
esperaría eso como fortalecimiento para
la democracia esto por supuesto
dependerá de el comportamiento de los
demás partidos políticos y de la la
posibilidad de que la upe y otras
propuestas diversas comiencen a tener
una representación efectiva en congreso
consejos
bueno todas las instancias de
representación a nivel nacional y por
este lado Néstor Qué significa esto para
un proceso electoral a futuro
creo que es el mensaje que la violencia
y la política no se pueden volver a
mezclar y y tiene que haber una sanción
digamos simbólica de parte de la
ciudadanía de no justificar este tema de
la violencia política que ha sido lo que
nos lleva un baño de sangre más de
250.000 muertos y siete millones de
desplazados Entonces es como ese mensaje
de que no no se puede justificar ningún
tipo de violencia política porque eso
fue lo que nos sucedió en los 80s en los
noventas y hasta hace poco era que decía
no pero es que el antagonista sea
guerrill yo paramilitar hizo lo mismo
entonces justificaba un discurso y un
discurso contra insurgente o un discurso
en su momento guerrillero que nos llevó
a una espiral de violencia y como dice
el padre Leonel Narváez el problema de
la venganza de la violencia es que es
como un bosque uno sabe cómo entra pero
nunca ni cuándo ni cómo va a salir
después de que nos metamos a una guerra
no sabemos cómo vamos a salir de ella
efectivamente sabía Esa esa analogía que
hace vamos llegando ya al bloque final
quiero que hagamos entonces las
conclusiones de lo que deja este proceso
condena al Estado colombiano lo que se
puede esperar entonces a futuro por
parte de los diferentes actores que
están involucrados en este episodio de
la política colombiana un par de minutos
para hacer la conclusión comienzo
entonces con Adriana por este lado
Adriana los factores positivos negativos
y a futuro siempre lo digo no tenemos la
bola de cristal para saber esto que va a
suceder pero desde su análisis qué se
puede proyectar factores positivos en
términos de la estructura el posible
fortalecimiento de los partidos
políticos el momento de oportunidad de
que el partido en poder esté alguien
alineado con los ideales de el
movimiento que es reconocido en este
momento como víctima de la up la defensa
al derecho a la libertad de expresión y
de libre asociación también que
motivaría a que otros partidos políticos
surjan se estructuren y se fortalezcan
en el proceso que sería como la
actualidad podríamos pensar en el cambio
de una cultura política insisto en las
nuevas generaciones que los jóvenes que
tienen movimientos políticos y sociales
mucho más fuertes hoy en día que hace 20
30 años puedan continuar con esta este
camino con esta lucha y con el poder
expresar sus ideas en la democracia sus
ideas no de manera disminuida sino en un
verdadero debate Y eso implica que
además dejemos de tener una cultura
política que en ocasiones es de súbdito
nosotros tendemos a personalizar la
política a creer que está en una sola
persona y por lo tanto hacer caso para
que sea democracia tenemos que
participar y que proponer y a futuro
estaría un tema de oportunidad de poder
fortalecer los procesos de paz que este
gobierno ha tomado como una bandera
política con los matices que vengan al
lugar con los distintos movimientos
reconociendo como decía Néstor que cada
uno de los del conflicto tiene una
estructura por mediología distinta y que
hace parte de nuestra diversidad
finalmente a futuro vería también la
posibilidad de retornar a las a las
campañas políticas en los municipios más
pobres de Colombia la Colombia rural
porque es parte de la ideología de estos
partidos políticos que no buscan
únicamente los electores en las grandes
ciudades y altas instancias Néstor su
conclusión para el cierre
tres cosas rápidas lo primero es que
necesitamos resultados en términos de
Justicia la impunidad la generadora de
nuevas violencias Necesitamos saber y
ese va a ser el reto para la justicia
colombiana Cómo se llamaban los
determinadores de todos estos muertos
Mientras tanto va a seguir la impunidad
Y eso alimenta nuevas violencias porque
los delincuentes dicen Si no les pasó a
ellos que hay una corte de la de una
sentencia de la corte no me va a pasar
nada a mí si sigo matando a líderes
sociales lo segundo es un reto para el
gobierno Petro también porque él fue
también digamos perseguido chuzado y es
el momento digamos de generar un hito
histórico en su gobierno de realmente
hacer una transformación en la justicia
y que haya Esto entonces Petro tiene una
un gran reto y lo tercero lo que más los
colombianos hemos muchos hemos
acobijados la jurisdicción especial para
la Paz es el único mecanismo que nos
garantiza algo de verdad en este
conflicto lo han intentado acabar desde
desde la derecha en Colombia pero es la
única que nos ha contado Cómo fueron los
falsos positivos Cómo fueron las
masacres etcétera etcétera la única
esperanza de Justicia que tiene hoy las
víctimas se llama la jurisdicción
especial para la paz pues me quedo con
esas dos conclusiones y reflexiones de
nuestros invitados del programa de hoy
Adriana Néstor Muchísimas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros Haber puesto
en contexto este tema de la realidad
colombiana para la audiencia de Francis
24 en América Latina episodio importante
para la política y para la salud de los
partidos políticos y para la historia
del conflicto colombiano por eso lo
hemos analizado Hoy acá En nombre del
equipo técnico Les agradecemos a ustedes
también la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]